[Musique]
bonsoir
une femme fait environ quarante deux ans
de cycle masqué roulait soit 546 six
coups de sa vie et cela fait plaisir
[Musique]
mais est-ce que vous avez subi ce
traitement
je n'avais pas imaginé qu'on allait
avoir des enfants de moins de 10 ans
d'âge
mais pour les hommes qui le serait pas
vous avez déjà entendu un jour votre
copie de votre femme vous dire que le
point qu'à ces mots que les anglais ont
débattu imaginez que vous avez maison
que vous devez mettre en location et
vous avez la possibilité de repeindre
les murs de cette maison
chaque mois jusqu'à trouver un locataire
c'est ma définition visiblement ce lien
vous convenez avec moi que ce phénomène
il est naturel et sans ce processus vous
et moi on n'allait pas être là ce soir
parce qu'on a j'avais entendu que
quelques années d'une fleur ou dunham
mais le hic c'est les ans pourquoi du
sein et n'a pas de l'eau du lait pour
bébés viennent
je ne saurais pas répondre à cette
question peut être que vous mais de ce
que je sais le sein à une valeur dans
nos sociétés dans le culture
il symbolise la vie et d'écoulement
ap st de par sa couleur et son espèce
n'est pas vêtement n'est pas
véritablement du sang parce qu'il est de
prouver qu'il n'a pas la même
proposition que le sang qui coule dans
nos veines
il est un concentré de l'us revin qui en
cas de grossesse servira à protéger les
foetus
pour la jeune femme en âge de procréer
en 2007 des chercheurs enfin une étude
ayant montré que le sang menstruel
comportait des cellules qui se situe
bien plus vite que les cellules souches
et ils ont conclu qu on avait là
désespoir il est dit pour fabriquer des
médicaments pour lutter contre des
maladies assez graves comme le cancer et
seidel maladies cardiovasculaires tous
le mensuel concerne la moitié de
l'humanité
et pourtant partout dans le monde les
femmes souffrent fait des règles et
elles sont souvent exclues des études de
l'unicef ont montré que une fille se
disent en afrique
madrid les armes à l'école bastien n'a
pas tout ce qu'il faut pour prendre soin
de ses bracelets 83% défis sont stressés
pendant la période et les évêques 1% son
karma absente de cette étude a été faite
le burkina et au niger et pour le
burkina encore le pm en vain
ça fait une étude sur l'hygiène
menstruel défunt et a montré que 65 %
des femmes pour ou qui n'en utilisent
des torches ou des chiffons alain la
période et si utiliser moins de
protection à 2010 est encore une jeune
fille népalais de 18 ans pourrait pas
suite des initiatives et des usines
monstre il est ce que l'exil masse via
sa société estimant que l'église est un
peu et toutes les jeunes filles et les
femmes ne doit pas dormir dans le foyer
familial pendant le règne
et c'est lors de cet exil puisque la
fille a dormi dehors qu'elle a été
mortellement mordu par un serpent dans
la société encore les règles
ali dere toujours un tableau leur dirais
que c'est une affaire de femmes et
depuis lundi quitté le tour les femmes
n'ayant pas trouvé des moyens pour se
protéger cela a mêlé les hommes à
conclure que les prêts ils sont plus et
que les femmes n'avaient pas de place
pas malheureux il possède de la société
c'est finalement vers le 19e siècle on a
trouvé des moyens pacifiques pour la
protection des femmes banane et règle
chez nous en afrique spécialement au
burkina en cultiver le coton
donc on avait la contournante et les
femmes utilisé des morceaux de tissus
pour se protéger mais jusqu'aujourd'hui
ces méthodes sont plus confortables vrai
c'est vous dire comme un jeu sera
présent les règles constituent un
problème dans le cc
ma bataille commence avec soin d'elle j
adele à 11
et lorsqu'elle jouait dans la cour de
récréation avec ses camarades sa
protection hygiénique est habile il n'a
plus jamais voulu revenir à l'école
parce que ses camarades se sont dit m
j'ai personnellement souffert de rennes
douloureuse pendant l'adolescence j'ai
vécu la période
romain un handicapé et je cherchais un
moyen je me disais que à la retraite
j'aimerais faire quelque chose pour le
jour j parce qu'on en parle bas et à
deux ans de cela
j'étais à un stade de ma vie où je me
posais des questions
j'étais convaincu que j'étais parler
pour rien dire
faire des enfants de mariée avoir un
travail mais j'avais autre chose à faire
et quoi
à ce moment de questionnement
je dirais un peu les dépressions aussi
peut-être que certains connaissent ce
moment là j'ai participé à un concours
un coq ou de fond croyable pour la
promotion de l'entrepreneuriat au
burkina et malgré que je n'avais que
quatre jours pour déposer le dossier
j'ai persévéré heureusement pour moi mon
projet a été retenu avec trois autres
projets sur 49 projets et sur le fond
comme un genre
donc accompagné pour la création de mon
entreprise qui fait la promotion de
l'hygiène pense rien les femmes et les
jeunes filles à travers l'utilisation
des énergies lavables aux fabricants les
serviettes hygiéniques en utilisant
notre faso danfani et du coton bio et
c'est une solution qui est réutilisable
puisque les séduire sont lavables et
c'est une solution économique et sur la
durée
dans ce combat nous avons fixé comme
objectif d'aider d'énergie au matin à
vivre pleinement leur scolarité ou si
elles regroupaient à la préservation de
l'environnement
si vous ne savez peut-être pas mais les
statistiques montrent que des serviettes
hygiéniques jj tables sont pas bio
dégradable met ses 100 ans à se dégrader
vous vous imaginez quand vous passez
dans un rating vous voyez une poubelle
et des serviettes de femmes et des
enfants qui jouent à goody nous faisons
aussi des sensibilisation sur les
dangers que les et des servites jj table
qui sont vendus dans nos sociétés parce
que beaucoup de ces serviettes ne sont
pas faites avec du coton mais du papier
les hippies et c'est ce récit plage
utilisent des produits chimiques qui
sont assez dangereux pour la santé
conclut aussi il fallait le considèrent
les femmes avec m
vous avez l'éducation mensuel et des
transmises par les verts à la jeune
fille qui venait d'avoir serré mais dans
le modèle en vue aujourd'hui et la
facilité de nous avons avec les
évitables cette éducation pas si souvent
agités juste un kit de coucher pour la
jeune fille à lui dire
à partir de maintenant doit plus jouer
avec les garçons parce que du p3 est
bien là mais bien se sont entendu dire
si tu vas les collections world invasion
qui changent de sens vraiment dit
pourquoi c'est vous dire que nous avons
perdu le sens de cette éducation mensuel
allocution vous louez à cette éducation
et si les femmes prenaient cela qu'on
est pour savoir que par la couleur des
raids et peuvent connaître si elles sont
importantes en europe 1 je vous invite à
vous renseigner le sujet ce projet les
serviettes et j lavable a changé ma vie
j'ai je pense qu elles aient peur de ma
vie j'ai compris le sens de mon nom et
j'ai aussi repris n'hésitez pas un
hasard si j'étais passé pas de règles
douloureuses et un internat de
m'attaquer
enfin ce problème qui est un rêve parce
que il nécessite des moyens je vais des
personnels de la santé jeu
peut déjà faire quelque chose pour les
jeunes filles et je me bats au quotidien
pour que la règle soit plus un handicap
dans la vie des jeunes filles dans la
vie le travail ont beaucoup de problèmes
nous avons beaucoup de challenges mais
c'est une réaction face à ces falaises
qui font la différence n'est pas
interdit de tomber
mais c'est sur un lit surélevé pour moi
a été d'être albal un moment le camp
dirais que c'était la dépression mais à
apprendre beaucoup
j'ai eu la france débouté les vidéos
inspirées des messages religieux mais
aussi d'étudier la vie de personnes qui
ont traversé les mêmes difficultés que
moi mais qui n'ont pas baissé les bras
j'avais constamment cette image de mon
enfance vous quand j'étais petit je
prenne à marcher je tombais je leur ai
livré tous les jours jusqu'à pouvoir
marcher dans ces moments difficiles
la roumanie
ici je garde toujours cette image et je
répète que tout petit
au bout d'une heure nous n'avons pas
abandonné juste un marché alors pourquoi
est ce qui nous arrive aujourd'hui j'ai
aussi étudié la vie de ces grands
entrepreneurs en business man tu enfin
fortune et qui un jour ont tout
abandonné pour se retrouver dans un
monastère en quête de sens à leur vie
je conclus alors nous ne sont pas nés
par hasard et pour paraphraser qui va
rester une voiture est censé fonctionner
avec du carburant et servait de l'eau ne
peut pas avancer j'ai l'ultime
conviction
comme l'a dit il est clair que nous ne
pouvons pas être heureux dans la vie si
nous n'apportons pas de la lumière dans
la vie des autres ce bonheur le voulons
tous et avec le livret de ce soir je
souhaite si ce n'est déjà fait que vous
trouverez aussi votre mission de vie
cheuvreux passé